[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
et
e
[Musique]
et
mais
je m'appelle yaron herman je suis
pianiste se gênent de paris et je
jouerai vendredi avec michel portal ya
un immense musicien une légende vivante
et avec mon trio basse heimburger à la
basse et ziv rabbits à la batterie on va
jouer les bons c'est de notre dernier
album y est sorti chez blue note
mais il ya quelques jours et on est ravi
de présenter sa musique pour la première
fois sur cette magnifique île la réunion
quand moi je découvre personnellement
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
disons que le jazz est une musique qui
en brasse le métissage de manière
générale et qui sait sublimer des
influences différentes au sein d'une
colonne vertébrale qu'est
l'improvisation dans ta musique de
l'instant
et par les temps qui courent je crois
que l'instant et apprécier l'instant
dans tout ce qu'il a des beaux de pures
et sincères et quelque chose que le jazz
nous permet de faire c'est ça qu'on va
essayer de transmettre aussi à partager
à travers notre musique
et
[Musique]